Hello there, I'm Simon Pegg.
And I'm Eva Noblezada.
Eva Noblezada:
In the new movie LUCK, one
young woman discovers a magical realm
Eva Noblezada:
where all of the world's
good luck
Eva Noblezada:
and bad luck is created.
But, did you know that what
may be considered lucky
in one place, might be totally
unlucky somewhere else?
Let's test our lucky knowledge
with this "quiz" on luck around
the world.
Good luck to us both.
Okay, black cats?
The one thing that we learned in
this movie is, they're unlucky
one place,
and lucky in another.
They are lucky in Scotland.
Scotland.
-Right place.
Scotland! (Imitates accent)
My turn.
A dragon?
I feel like that's gonna be
lucky in parts of Asia, don't
you think?
Yeah!
Lucky China.
-Lucky.
Ooh.
-Ooh.
A Bunyip?
Simon Pegg: Ha!
Eva Noblezada:
And not the kind
that's treatable.
I've got a terrible Bunyip,
doctor.
I think that's Australia, isn't
it, a Bunyip?
Unlucky!
-Oh, unlucky!
How unlucky are you?
Stop.
This is getting ridiculous.
Saying "Rabbit" on a boat?
Rabbits!
(Marching)
I'd say lucky.
Oh, I was about to...
You were gonna rip it off.
-(Laughs)
I get very excited.
I'm really excited to open it.
-You're so impatient.
Unlucky in France!
France.
Mais oui.
-Aah!
Parle-vous francais?
Oui.
-Oui? Yeah.
Aah!
-Petit fois.
Simon Pegg:
A very simple orange?
(Laughing)
Oh, I thought that was a
description-a very simple orange!
And what do you think, Spain?
Because oranges in...
-Probably Spain.
-Seville, and all that stuff.
-Or Portugal.
China.
-Oh, that's right. It's a, yeah.
Did you know that?
-I did know that, somewhere in
there.
You go.
-Dunk, dunk dunk.
Ooh!
Hat on a bed?
Oh, it's unlucky in Italy, but
it's also unlucky in New
Orleans.
I think.
What do you think, New Orleans?
Eva Noblezada:
Let's see.
Give us a ring on this number.
-Ding.
-Laughs.
A boomerang?
Eva Noblezada:
It can go go either way.
They can go either way.
Laughing.
-Keep going.
They go and come back.
1-2-3.
-Lucky Australia.
Lucky Australia!
(Smack)
-Yes!
Yellow T-shirt?
Eva Noblezada:
I feel like that's unlucky in,
Spain.
Unlucky in Spain!
You're so on it.
Ooh, eating lentils on New
Year's Eve?
And let's face it, if you eat
lentils on New Year's Eve,
Everyone else is gonna be
unlucky on New Year's Day.
It's lucky in Italy.
(Clapping)
Ooh!
(Snort)
-Pig?
Where are they lucky?
Germany, not so much.
Because of sausages.
Hmm.
Wasn't funny.
Yeah, not my best.
Ooh, lucky in Austria.
-Austria.
I think I know what this is.
(Whispers)
-I'm not saying anything.
(Laughing)
But wait, touch wood.
You're wrong.
-Ooh!
Or knock on it, don't they?
-But, this-this-this is
different though.
-It's poking wood.
That's how different ballgame.
-That's poking wood.
I'm gonna say lucky.
This is falling apart.
-(Laughs)
Lucky.
Lucky in the United Kingdom.
Yeah!
The Hei Tiki?
Simon Pegg:
That feels like something from
New Zealand, perhaps?
I would say lucky.
Lucky in New Zealand.
For five-hundred...
Lucky in New Zealand!
-Ooh!
Good answer.
♪♪
Feeling lucky?
Then be sure to check out the
new Apple original film, "Luck",
Eva Noblezada:
Now streaming on Apple TV+.
♪♪
Make it rain!
- Good luck.